i've got some breaking news to bring you
on sky news tonight the chancellor's
wife has announced that she will pay uk
taxes on her overseas income this
follows criticism over her tax reducing
non-domiciled status live to westminster
and our deputy political editor sam
coats uh some bring us up to date then
with this breaking news that's right
it's frankly been pretty much the worst
week that rishi soon at the chancellor
has had since taking office in early
2000's not only has he today had to
confirm the revelations from sky news
overnight that he was essentially uh
holding a u.s green card entitling him
to live in the united states uh all the
way through his rise up the ministerial
ranks and including into about 18 months
of his time as chancellor which has
prompted awkward questions but today
just now in the last 10 minutes his wife
has issued the most personal statement i
have seen from the spouse of a prime
minister about her own private affairs
her relationship with her husband all
off the back of those revelations
confirmed by the treasury that she is
non-domiciled in other words she doesn't
have to pay tax on her overseas income
let me read you some of the things that
she's saying
it is a lengthy statement but it's
unusual for a politician so worth uh
delving in some detail since arriving in
the uk uh chateau murti says i have been
made to feel more welcome than i ever
could have imagined both in london and
our home in north yorkshire it's a
wonderful country and then she goes on
in recent days people have asked
questions about my tax arrangements
and to be clear i've paid tax in this
country it's entirely legal what i'm
doing but it has become clear that many
people don't feel this is compatible
with my husband's role as chancellor now
this bit is key i understand and i
appreciate the british sense of fairness
and i do not wish my tax status to be a
distraction for my husband or to affect
my family she goes on to say that is why
she is announcing not only will she pay
uk tax on her uk income but now despite
being a non-dom she will pay uk tax on
all of her worldwide income so that's a
big change she says i've tried to keep
my professional life and my personal
life separate ever since rishi entered
parliament uh but uh uh they have they
have lived together in lots of countries
overseas um and she says that none of
this will change her decision
that the india remains the country of
her birth her citizenship her parents
home and the place of her domicile but
she loves the uk too
for a politician's wife to have to put
out such a statement after what she
seems like is queen quite upfront and
making clear has been a really difficult
time seeing her dragged into the
spotlight has been incredibly tough for
this family he and she will be hoping
that this draws a line under it but
given the scale of the questions it's
hard to know whether it will now let's
find out what else has been going on
going on and going wrong for rishi sunak
today
always looking at home here the
stateside chancellor this time on an
official visit
but so much of his life has been here on
the west coast santa monica where he
comes to relax and have things gone to
plan should have been over easter at his
holiday home
but after days of criticism over his
wife's tax affairs and his own
undeclared u.s ties he'll now spend it
here richmond in yorkshire his
constituency home
do people around here still think he's
one of them i do kind of feel
they perhaps don't live in the real
world because they're wealthy the poor
get poor and the richer they're richer
and come on do you think he's scraping
around eating hines baked beans for
dinner tonight of course he's not i
don't have any different views about him
he's just doing his job at the end of
the day like everybody has a job to do
rishi sunak's boss boris johnson had to
take time out from meeting the new
german chancellor to defend him when
asked firstly whether he knew about the
fine print of his wife's tax
arrangements and secondly if number 10
had been briefing them to the press
he said number one no uh number two um
if if there are such uh briefings i've
they're certainly not uh coming from us
in uh in number ten heaven knows where
they are coming from and number three uh
i think the answer is emphatically yes
i think that rishi is doing an
absolutely outstanding job this isn't
ultimately about the detail of rishi
tsunak's arrangements his wife's tax
affairs or they're quite sizable wealth
this is about a chancellor at the helm
in the worst cost of living squeeze for
over 50 years and whether he truly
understands the challenges that ordinary
families are facing
today's major headache for rishi sunak
having to confirm sky news revelations
that he held a u.s green card entitling
him to live in the united states for
eight years after he left while moving
through ministerial ranks and even for
18 months as chancellor tonight he's
arguing holding a green card didn't mean
he ought to live in the u.s
but this american immigration expert
disagreed certainly from a u.s
immigration standpoint when a person has
a green card they are meant to reside in
the united states they are a lawful
permanent resident that is the official
title and they are meant to be a
resident in the u.s
the opposition now holding up a red card
when they're appointed to a new office
ministers must provide their civil
servants with uh all the writing in
writing all uh their interests it really
looks like the chancellor failed to meet
the minister of code in many respects
and given he's also failing to help
people with the cost of living i really
think
he now needs to go he should resign
richie's next most difficult period in
office so far but to remain as
chancellor he will have to accept a
permanent level of scrutiny on him his
wife and his family affairs
is this a price worth paying sam coat
sky news westminster